dos ministros clave del gobierno
británico de emitieron con pocos minutos
de diferencia a través de sus cuentas de
twitter
de la cartera de economía y salir del
despacho de salud
ambos renunciaron en protestas por los
escándalos que han salpicado la
administración del primer ministro
británico boris johnson y en las cartas
de renuncia cuestionaron su capacidad de
liderazgo los ciudadanos esperan con
mucha razón que el gobierno se comporte
de forma adecuada competente y seria
reconozco que este puede ser mi último
cargo ministerial pero creo que vale la
pena luchar por estas normas y por eso
dimito ha sido un enorme privilegio
servir en esta función pero lamento no
poder seguir con la conciencia tranquila
las renuncias llegaron en un acto casi
coreografiado justo después de que
saliera a la luz que el líder tenía
conocimiento de una denuncia por
conducta sexual inapropiada contra el ex
diputado conservador crispin chair y
pese a ello lo designó como responsable
de la disciplina del grupo parlamentario
conservador algo por lo que johnson
pidió excusas watson stay kearns
sí creo que fue un error y me disculpo
por ello creo que en retrospectiva no
fue lo correcto ofrezco disculpas a
todos los que se han visto gravemente
afectados por eso pero la disculpa
apareció no ser suficiente y su gabinete
empezó a desmoronarse con la salida de
sus aliados más cercanos tan sólo un mes
después de que johnson sobreviviera a
una votación de confianza en su contra
por el escándalo conocido como para
gates en el que tanto johnson como
miembros del gobierno rompieron las
reglas de salud en pleno confinamiento
por el cob y 19 muchos de sus
legisladores están cada vez más
frustrados al tener que defender a una
administración plagada de escándalos y
vuelve a sonar la posibilidad de que
johnson abandone su cargo como primer
ministro